[Music]
our series of more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as americans is
far greater than what divides us
this morning we look at members of the
next generation aiming to do
just that adriana diaz introduces us to
a group of teenagers some of them too
young
to vote who are working to strengthen
their communities
and american democracy itself
from protesting gun violence to rallying
against climate change
generation z has raised its voice to
change the world
i think generation z is the most diverse
most educated and most interconnected
generation
we have a unique perspective and a
unique energy to not only change
significant issues in the country but
change the systems behind the issues
seventeen-year-old fenassi delos is one
of those change makers
in may 2019 he co-founded civics
unplugged
an organization helping more than 400
students craft
and fund their passion projects they all
serve
a common goal it's to push america
forward it's to get kids more educated
and it's to serve democracy we've
learned that we can harness the power of
change
and we can take our specific and unique
strengths to
actually turn change into action
sixteen-year-old nur ryan wanted to give
her peers a productive outlet after
covid19 canceled summer plans
so she co-created an online civics camp
we're all living through unprecedented
times and we figured why not make a use
out of the time we have at home
eighteen-year-old harvard freshman
terena ahuja wanted to see more empathy
in public policy so she started a think
tank
called the greater good initiative
working to write nonpartisan policy
in the areas of education public health
economy civil rights and environment
and these are teenagers writing policy
for the us government
yes and we have like 70 page briefs
you take the raw and genuine passion of
young
people you pair that with resources and
then
you know after that you have a supernova
of action seventeen-year-old kentuckian
zoe jenkins saw vital lessons missing
from her education
so she wrote her own curriculum to teach
students about diversity equity and
anti-racism
we talk about the differences between
race and ethnicity and really educate
people on things that our education
system should have already taught them
a lot of it is teaching people it's okay
to not know though their youth comes
with advantages
it can also be used against them we were
advocating for
um you know increasing the number of
school counselors we got a response of
oh you guys should set up a little bake
sale and raise money and it's like
that's not
real policy change do you guys think
your generation gets a bad rap
yes i guess we do have that reputation
for being engrossed in technology
but the really cool thing is we're also
using those things to achieve some of
these missions
sending messages on tick tock about
empathy about social
justice about how to vote or using
instagram and snapchat to amplify
stories that haven't been heard
if i can cause 100
200 kids to become inspired and start
their own projects and i think my work
has been a success
thanasis says civics unplugged which is
non-profit and nonpartisan
has partnered with major foundations
securing one million dollars in pledges
to support these student projects
i'm watching you and i have to remind
myself you're just 17 years old you look
like
a veteran politician i think that social
media
and covid has accelerated our
development
we don't have time to wait till we
graduate college to make change
change changes to happen right now we're
the generation that
came of age after 9 11. we're also all
coming of age during a global pandemic
in the new civil rights movement but i
don't think we've ever had a sense of
urgency
like what we're seeing right now and
with their potential unplugged
they say their reach has no limits for
cbs this morning
i'm adriana diaz wow that's an
impressive group of kids
so i wanted to know what does gen z mean
the ages from 17 to 22.
yeah so because i think what i was doing
at 17 to 22. not that
those guys are amazing i know i know you
also worry for them though they're
coming out of school if you're 22 in the
to the 24 range and
you're looking at a job market where
people are losing their positions at a
huge rate
the numbers just came out a few moments
ago we had uh 800 000 additional people
applying for unemployment insurance
26 million people on benefits right now
so you can see why they're getting
involved yeah interesting to see too the
point they make that the corona
virus makes them feel they need to
accelerate things you know
the urgency they feel it strongly